STEVE: WE JUST HEARD WHAT THE
LONG TERM FALLOUT COULD BE.
BIG BUSINESS TAKEOVER.
LET’S GIVE THEM ONE EACH.
TAMMY YOU TAKE THE END OF
GLOBALISM.
>> WELL, THAT IS, AND IT WOULD
BE AN EXTRAORDINARY RESULT OF
THIS, OBVIOUSLY CHINA HAS AN
INTEREST IN IT CONTINUING,
OTHER ENTITIES DO AS WELL AND
THEY ARE GOING TO FIGHT TO
MAINTAIN THIS.
WE KNOW THEY CHEAT AND THEY
LIVE SO IT’S GOING TO BE A
FIGHT BUT AT THE SAME TIME IF
ANYONE CAN CONFRONT IT, TRUMP
HAS BEEN DOING THAT FROM THE
BEGINNING EVERY SINGLE ONE OF
HIS DECISIONS RANGING FROM
TRADE, THE ISSUE OF THE
BORDER, THE NATURE OF AMERICA
FIRST, SO MANY PEOPLE WERE
VERY UPSET WITH THAT SLOGAN,
AND NOW WE UNDERSTAND THE
NATURE OF HOW THAT’S
IMPORTANT.
IT DOESN’T JUST HELP US, IT IN
FACT WILL MAKE THE REST OF THE
WORLD HEALTHIER AS WELL.
>> I CAN’T HELP THINKING WHEN
I SAW PETER NAVARRO, THIS WAS
HIS MOMENT.
CAN YOU TAKE THE BIG
GOVERNMENT TAKE OVER THAT I’M
VERY NERVOUS ABOUT, WHAT YOU
THINK ABOUT THAT.
>> WHILE IN SOME WAYS THAT’S
ALREADY HAPPENED.
WE DID SOMETHING VERY
DANGEROUS TWO WEEKS AGO WHEN
WE PASSED THAT BILL BECAUSE
FOR ALL THE MONEY WE ARE SO
PENDING ON SMALL BUSINESSES
INCORPORATION, THE BIGGEST
CHUNK OF THAT MONEY WENT TO
GOVERNMENT ITSELF.
IT MIGHT’VE BEEN THE BIGGEST
SINGLE DAY INCREASE OF
GOVERNMENT POWER IN THE
HISTORY OF THIS COUNTRY.
CAN I GET A LITTLE OPTIMISTIC
FLIPSIDE, I’M ALSO THINKING OF
IT THIS WAY.
HERE’S AN OPPORTUNITY TO COME
OF THE OPPORTUNITY IS, WHEN
YOU HAVE EMERGENCIES,
GOVERNMENTS ARE FORCED TO PUT
ASIDE REGULATIONS AND SPEED
THINGS UP.
YOU’RE SEEING THAT FROM THE
FDA, CHANGES IN TRUCK
REGULATIONS, THIS IS THE
MOMENT FOR EVERYONE TO BE
ASKING, DID WE NEED THOSE IN
THE FIRST PLACE AND DO WE
REALLY NEED THEM TO COME
BACK.
I SEE SOME REAL OPPORTUNITY
THERE.
>> FANTASTIC POINT.
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH.
I REALLY LOVE THAT POINT.
ALL RIGHT CHARLIE, BIG
BUSINESS TAKEOVER.
I’M VERY ANXIOUS ABOUT THAT AS
WELL.
>> YES, AND YOU SHOULD BE.
LOOK, I THINK THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE NEED TO REMEMBER AND
ASKED THE QUESTION, WHY IS IT
THAT SOME OF THESE BUSINESSES
DOMINATE ESSENTIAL PRODUCTION
WITHIN CHINA AND IT’S EXPOSING
OUR SUPPLY CHAIN.
IT’S EXPOSING THAT SOME OF THE
MOST NEEDED PHARMACEUTICALS
FOR OUR COUNTRY ARE HALFWAY
AROUND THE WORLD TO A COUNTRY
THAT COULD TURN OFF THE LIGHTS
INSTANTANEOUSLY.
I’M LIKE YOU, I’M REALLY
WORRIED BECAUSE RIGHT NOW
YOU’RE GONNA SEE BUSINESSES,
YOU’RE GOING TO SEE COMPANIES
THAT HAVE A CASH ON HAND, THEY
ARE GOING TO SURVIVED US IN
THE SMALL BUSINESSES RIGHT NOW
THAT ARE JUST BARELY GETTING
BY WITH 8 - 10 EMPLOYEES WHICH
IS THE BACKBONE OF THIS
EMPLOYEE WHICH IS THE ENGINE
OF OUR PRODUCTIVITY, IT’S ON
MAIN STREET, IT’S A SMALL
MANUFACTURING PLANT.
I DON’T WANT TO SEE THEM GO
UNDER.
I DON’T WANT TO SEE US BECOME
A CRONY CAPITALIST PSEUDO-
PSEUDO- SOCIALIST COUNTRY
WHERE THE COMPANIES THAT HAVE
ACCESS TO K STREET AND THE
RIGHT LOBBYING FIRM AND ARE
ABLE TO PICK UP THE PHONE AND
GET A SENATOR ON THE LINE, I
DON’T WANT TO SEE THEM GET
STRONGER BECAUSE OF THIS.
I WANT TO SEE THE EXACT
OPPOSITE.
I WANT TO SEE MAINSTREET AND
ENTREPRENEURS AND SMALL
BUSINESSES ACTUALLY GET MORE
BUSINESS, MORE POWER AND
ENTREPRENEURS BE LIBERATED AND
WE LEARN OUR LESSON OF WHAT
HAPPENS WITH MUCH POWER AND
PURCHASING POWER WITHIN A
SMALL COLLECTION OF COMPANIES
THAT QUITE HONESTLY HAVE NOT
ALWAYS BEEN MAKING DECISIONS
IN OUR COUNTRY’S BEST
INTEREST.
STEVE: REALLY WELL PUT.
KIM, I THINK THAT GOES TIGHTLY
TOGETHER WITH THE POINT YOU
JUST MADE THAT BIG BUSINESS
AND BIG GOVERNMENT OFTEN
THRIVE TOGETHER.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
SO WE NEED TO BE ON GUARD.
WE ALSO NEED TO BE VIEWING
THIS AS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
RETHINK GOVERNMENT AND ASKED
THE QUESTION OF WHO’S DOING
THE MOST GOOD AND RESPOND TO
THIS AND HOW DO WE MAKE SURE
THAT OUR BUSINESS SECTOR,
WHETHER IT’S BIG BUSINESS.